attracted to 50 year olds like I think I
can be like I'm not physically attracted
to them I mean Mark Ruffalo I would call
him daddy any day of the week what's
what's what's the oldest you would
actually consider for a husband
uh 15 20.
years old no years older
no it's like you no no no no
like five so maybe 45. so you would
consider a a 40 year old guy seriously
for marriage and suit yeah if you're no
kids sure most of them most of them
probably have children but like if you
look good no kids sign me up how about
you all right it would really depend
because I know some like men who are
post 50 who are really they're running
like Iron Man's triathlons so so if they
were like they want to marry you start a
life with you you'd be open to that
do you know what I'm gonna be real
honest I I would I would be a gold
digger if there is an 80 year old man on
his deathbed who is like
I I would do it I would do it for that
easy life there's there's no limit age
limit for you
I mean realistically yeah there is like
that's me just like
kind of like being realistically I'm
like
oh [ __ ] I don't know because oh there's
a lot of [ __ ] to go in there like even
like Health even like how open are they
to travel how committed are they to
their job how like no all those things
are there I'm just saying the age what's
the age limit
doesn't it
fur guys my
they're usually more like looking for
something casual yeah so that's how I
like guys in their mid-30s not because
I'm more attracted to them but just
because like they're kind of in this
like I don't know they're not in like
the Casual yeah you know it's weird like
I
and get butchered out here if I say this
um I feel like for a mental thing I
prefer women who are older to actually
talk to on a on a on a standard basis
I'd say is generalization
but then if it's just casual fun then to
be honest it's kind of if she's
attractive I have a heart take I think
girls peek at like 18.
the time yeah yeah roads must you says
like 22-23 I think personally for me I
would I would say and we're talking
General I would say 24 25 because that's
when I say she's still like if she was
hot at 22 she's not gonna not be hot at
24. do you know what I mean but she's
probably more mature and I value that I
think that 18 year olds look the best
because most girls
most girls don't gain weight in college
I know but they just look like most
girls get like beer bellies
call it I just think I just think like
because I'm I'm at that age where girls
who hit on me are around that age yeah
and I find it weird because they just
look like children to me yeah whereas
I'm like now I wanna I want a woman yeah
a young woman but I want a woman you
know what I mean like I feel like I
don't know that's why that's why it's
like
yeah I just yeah I couldn't I couldn't
like I couldn't get a girl who looked
incredibly young looking I'd feel weird
I know some guys love that [ __ ] but
that's I don't know 18 year olds
nowadays look like they're 25. oh
okay I'm like I see I'm like what the I
don't know
but yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't go lower
than 23 though he wouldn't go lower than
23. yeah I remember the day that old
guys got hot it was really weird it was
like I didn't see guys I did when I was
21 or 22. I was going on dates with a
guy that was 30 and I just couldn't get
past it I was like I can't he's so old
I remember like thinking like
oh he's 30 like that's so old and but
now I remember being like 24 I mean like
are 40 year olds attract our dad's hot
yes oh my God it was a weird it was so
weird it didn't happen until like 24 23
maybe I was like oh this is strange this
is strange I have a question for both of
you is there a diff well
what would you say is your dating age
range but then your sleeping casual
sexual age range so for me I would
personally happily sleep with someone
who was like 21 but I wouldn't date
someone who was 21. I wouldn't like
yeah I kind of I don't look for it all
just like it's the same to me okay wait
I don't know serious okay no no
seriously like yeah like oh like between
casual and serious uh I'd say casual
anywhere between
23 to like
I mean I've dated a woman in her late
40s before so I'd say like 23 to like 48
if we're talking series I need to see
what she looks like I need
if I wasn't going to be serious about
someone I definitely the younger they
are I'm like it doesn't matter
let me see okay
I'm Gonna Keep the mic this way and I'm
just gonna hope that you why you still
got it for kids sake I'm gonna oh is
that a why you still got it well he's
still got it excuse me
is that is that is that a thing don't
guys keep like albums of all the nudes
they have well it might if I end things
with a guy I have to I say to them I'm
like respectfully I would like you to
delete anything I've sent you but
[Music]
um
[Applause]
oh they get or if they get a girl that's
like I need you to delete this but I'm
fully aware that if I ever send
something I'm fully aware I'm fully
aware that if I send something to
someone that I'm and I don't advocate
for it at all but I'm aware that one
they're probably going to show some of
their male friends I know that I know
that it's happened to me before that
they'll be like this is a girl I'm
sleeping with this the guy I'm dating
I'm well aware that if I send something
that's it uh it's it goes back to
consequences if I send a nude photo or a
promiscuous photo I am well aware that
it probably will not just stay in his
phone or with him and it probably will
not end when I wanted any comments on
this on what I'm the album
listen ladies
if you send a guy a nude photo it is on
his phone forever that's all I'm gonna
say and I say this I say this in my
videos you guys you guys show each other
their girlfriends nudes not their
girlfriends just like random hoes so
yeah so if they're okay so if there's a
girl that he's not taken seriously yeah
she sends him a nude he's showing it to
his closest I'll be honest he is
but if it's his girlfriend no [ __ ]
way that shit's his no way and even if
it was an X because it's like yeah it's
it's a respect thing isn't it it's a
respect thing
what about girls because they get dick
pics all the time what do you guys do
with that nothing personally I actually
can't [ __ ] sound it I'm like dog pics
over dick pics when people say my dick
pic I do the fake like oh wow I
literally don't give a [ __ ] I don't
think I've ever gotten a dick pic not
like not like a one I asked for like
I've had yeah yeah
but then have you have you ever felt the
need to ask someone no no that's a good
thing I can keep that to yourself and I
say that I say it's my guy friends I'm
like I'm gonna be real with you if a
girl has ever I mean never say never but
again if we go back to like majority and
exception I think majority of girls do
not give a [ __ ] and so if she's asking
for a dick pic she's probably just
trying to inflate your ego or act the
way she wants you to act yeah and same
with threesomes though I know a lot of
girls who are like oh I've had
threesomes and oh wait let's add it oh
wow what the [ __ ] she looks good okay
um with three I think more girls
actually like want to have three sons
than admitted just for the record that
was not an explicit pick that was a very
no it's just in her face it was just it
was just a very busy
but obviously that's nothing but yeah
yeah I think uh it's rough because some
girls want free stuff because
statistically I know I know the stats
like most girls if they're like surveyed
on it like would do a threesome but
would they do it because they want to or
would they do it because they know most
women are attracted to other women oh
100 oh 100 I would rather have a
threesome yeah oh 100 and it's like
really it really grinds my gears
especially on Tick Tock when girls are
like
oh girl crush or buy Panic or I'm
straight I'm straight I'm sorry you're
not your queer you're attracted to her
it's actually internalized homophobia to
be like oh I don't know I'm
uncomfortable being attracted to a woman
don't be you're attracted to a woman it
is what it is I mean I think there's
like levels there's like like the nurse
joint Pokemon when I was like six
I think they're thinking they're
attractive and like wanting to sleep
with them or like yeah yeah yeah yeah I
have a question why why is it as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible